i miss this outfit
i'll find an excuse to wear it again
hey folks so um
[Music]
this will be my picks for the
top 10 12th doctor
episodes it's uh kind of the end of an
era in a couple ways
um i should address this up front
instead of waiting for the back end
more than a few people have asked
whether or not take two doctor who
reviews are going to continue
into the 13th doctor's era with series
11 series 12.
um so here's my current plan for that
series 11
is definitely going to happen at some
point this year but not
immediately i actually need to take a
break from the wednesday uploads and go
to one video a week at least for a
little bit to try and get
um my feedback out of me get getting the
book out
well it's not out yet but getting the
book ready to get out uh
has just set me behind i used to have a
like a cushion of you know stuff shot in
advance and i really don't right now so
i need to rebuild all that a little bit
but at some point down the line
month maybe two i will do take two
reviews for
series 11. series 12 is probably going
to wait until
no after series 13 airs most likely
because honestly it's too fresh
it's the freshest stuff in my head and i
don't think i'm gonna have a new enough
take i don't think it's been enough time
but they will all happen
eventually but that's the plan for right
now so that having been said
let us take a look at what i think
are the 10 best episodes to star
peter capaldi as the 12th doctor
number 10 the pilot
this is easily my favorite start to
any of the series that he's in i think
it does
such a wonderful job setting up the
doctor's current status quo
establishing bill establishing what it
is about her
that sort of draws the doctor to her
makes her interested i just in general i
still
love the idea and the setup of the
doctor teaching at a university
like that's just i just love that on
principle and
i like the way it gets established i
like the way that the story pans out and
while i do have some reservations about
some of the aspects of
how heather is handled i do think the
way that
she pursues them is actually very tense
and very well done
the resolution is an interesting one and
it kind of sets up
a lot of what's going to go on the rest
of that series with
rather than needing a violent to this
thing must be stop solution it's
more about acts of kindness and empathy
and that's laying a lot of groundwork
for what was
ultimately i think a great series
number nine dark water and death
in heaven so this is a reminder that
when i do lists like this
i do count two parters as one story and
i suspect this is gonna be one of the
more
controversial entries because i know
plenty of people
um whose opinions i respect who really
really don't like this story i do
i'm not going to say that a lot of the
criticisms i've heard toward it aren't
valid but between the fact that it
really it doesn't it's technically not
the introduction to missy but i consider
it to be the introduction to missy
because it's when
she actually becomes a character instead
of a mystery box
and i really love michelle gomez in this
part
i love the answers that it gives to the
questions the doctor has been asking
about himself
for the for that entire series questions
of am i a good man and his answer and
the affirmation of who he is
and being comfortable with his place
in the universe i am
an idiot with a box
and a screwdriver i think it is
wonderful
i think the use of the cyberman's pretty
interesting in this as well i
personally like the resolution on danny
and clara's relationship i
like danny more than i think some people
do
but for me while there are
some weaknesses here the stuff that i
like about it
more than makes up for it i thought this
was a really solid closure
to that first series that capaldi had
and set up things well for
where his journey would go later
number eight thin ice this is one that
really got boosted quite a bit in my
reassessment of it when i did
the re-watch really just sort of seeing
how well everything just kind of pulls
together
again in terms of the thematics and a
lot of the recurring stuff across the
series
with it with its examination and its
criticism
of capitalism and the kind of behavior
that that motivates i love the fact that
the villain is
just a guy just a normal guy taking
advantage there is an alien involved but
the alien's not the problem
the greedy human is the way that we get
to see
that era of england portrayed just
felt fresh despite it not really being a
new time
setting for the doctor the way the
doctor and bill interact when
a child the episode kills a child so
like
okay um and then bill confronting him
about that like
how often do you see this kind of thing
like what is your life really like what
have you not been telling me
and watching the two of them come to
a slightly better understanding about
who they are and plus you know
the doctors saying oh words are the
better way and then just decking a
racist in the face
i support that
number seven under the lake and before
the flood
this is another really terrific two part
of the atmosphere is
mwah i want to kiss it to death it does
a really good build up of
between introducing the ghosts and the
way they operate and trying to figure
out how this works
and it doesn't waste a lot of time like
pretending ooh is it really ghosts like
well
we know it's something else let's try
and figure out what and building the
mystery around
what are they as opposed to trying to
play it like a surprise that it's going
to somehow involve aliens because we all
know that
at this point we know that's going to be
the case so it does
a really wonderful job playing with that
progression and the
um timing and the pacing at which the
both the characters in the audience
learn more about it there's terrifically
tense scenes um like when the sort of
head of the team
she's you know walking along and there's
this ghost dragging an axe binder and
she can't hear it
ah super tense i know some people
probably would have put this one a
little bit higher
um for me there are a couple of weird
oddities uh
in terms of like the way the second one
opens
the fischer king looks great but when he
gets out in daylight doesn't look
as good as i would like him doing
there's little things like that holding
him back but this really is
terrific stuff number
six face the raven now some people would
lump this as
a three-part story this heaven sent
hellbent i don't i actually consider
them
separate stories each is a sequel to the
one
before but it's not a continuous single
story it is a
complete story in each episode that then
sets up where the next one's gonna go
and i think face the raven was a really
excellent
sign off for clara it would get
undone two episodes later but within the
episode itself
especially with the build up over that
series
and her just getting too comfortable
getting cocky trying to be like the
doctor
and that behavior getting her killed
and the doctor who is so
certain that he can handle almost
anything and there's nothing he can do
this time
and it would have been really easy for
her death to feel
overblown and modeling and maybe it even
should
but for some reason it works i think
they managed to find the balance of it
really really well and while it's a
little underutilized i do find
the concept of the trap street actually
quite interesting as well so that was
a nice little extra layer on top of it
plus you know
i i just like ravens i do
yeah that's a that's a factor
[Music]
number five extremists
this episode based on premise
should not work it should not work at
all
but there's so many things that pull it
together first of all props to the show
for having extended consequences to the
fact that the doctor lost his eyesight
the previous episode and he's still
dealing with the consequences of that
the fact that his workarounds
aren't actually perfect and he's still
coming up short in ways
you know relying on the sunglasses and
it doesn't totally work but it gets him
by well enough until certain
situations where he's like oh god i
actually need my actual eyes
the introductions of the monks is very
creepy while the
follow-up two-parter with the monks i
know they call it the monk trilogy but
again i consider this one
self-contained that just sets up the
next ones
that introduction of them the idea of
them of them running these simulations
so that they know exactly
what to do when to arrive and how to
behave to take over a planet without
firing a
shot uh that entire concept is great i
love
the triumph of the doctor
who isn't even the doctor he's just a
program
and he has lost in the sense that like
he can't save the world it's not his
world to save it's all
fake but still has that triumphant
moment of sending the information
to the real doctor the smirk and just
like
the execution of the reveal that this is
all a simulation because that's the part
that really should have fallen apart
because it's an equivalent to it was all
a dream and like is there anything worse
and more cliche than that but
it works it makes it work and it
sells it really well
number four oxygen
this one is a beautiful
piece of science fiction and i mean that
in multiple ways
the use of the space setting and the use
of the threat of running out of air
is the kind of thing that you need
a space and sci-fi setting to do
i i always love when things happen
within a piece of genre fiction that you
couldn't do
in another genre if you moved it to
another genre you wouldn't be able to
tell the same story
and the use of oxygen just the lack of
it as a threat
in this environment that it could be
just taken away at a moment
and then the other thing that it does
which in my mind
any um sci-fi that is intending
to make a commentary on the model world
which most sci-fi
should anything that is meant to be
taking place in the future of the world
in which we live now
should have some kind of commentary
element the best way to do that right
is to take an aspect of right now blow
it up
to extreme proportions and this
does that with capitalism
and the treatment of employees by a
corporation who views them
as nothing other than a number
other than an asset other than data in a
spreadsheet and
does not ever consider them as human
beings
it is a terrific and biting commentary
and the exact kind of extrapolation
an extreme example of something that to
a lesser degree
does occur in the world that we live
that is how you do this kind of thing
right
it's tense it really does get under your
skin at points
tense you up and just be like this is so
wrong and so unfair
and it really pulls this off
number three the mummy on the orient
express
one of the dumbest titles for one of the
best episodes there's
almost too much to love about this i
love the blending of this more
classical looking set you know because
it's modeled after the orient express
yet it's in space and we have all these
sci-fi elements so i love the mix of
aesthetics right there
the supporting cast on this one is great
i really do
appreciate when uh a doctor who episode
has a strong supporting cast who all
feel like proper characters with their
own lives separate from the story
they're currently trapped in this has
that
in abundance the whole conceit
of the timer and having it there
watching it count down every time it
comes up
and so that the scenes playing out in
real time that is
really really wonderfully done it's so
tense and again this sort of this is one
of the
early examples that i think really nails
that the doctor defeats this thing
through understanding through coming to
realize
what it is and meeting it on its own
terms
this isn't something you fight this is
something
that you understand and empathize with
and in his case
give permission to stop i
oh so good
[Music]
number two heaven sent
oh yeah i am sure that i've surprised
some people
by not making this number one we'll get
there hold on
but this is
a freaking masterpiece
the ability of capaldi to hold the
screen
while being the only one there trapped
in this
horrible maze with this thing just
creeping behind him slowly all the time
him trying to figure out what's going on
the audience trying to figure out with
him
the slow sinking realization of
what it is that is happening to him and
how long it has been happening to him to
then
turn around and become one of the most
triumphant moments i've ever seen on
television
when you realize that he's getting
further into this story about the bird
every time he tells it and that means he
is chipping
away at the thing that has trapped him
and i personally choose to read this as
a metaphor for
grief i think it works excellently as
that other people have different reads
on it but
i think the triumph of that moment
stands no matter what your read on this
is
whatever you think it is that is
trapping him here that won't let him
escape
he can break it down but it's not going
to be
an instantaneous thing it takes time
it takes work it feels like you are just
punching a wall of diamond but
if you put in the work you can
break out of whatever it is that has
trapped you within a cycle
of pain that
is beautiful
it doesn't take my number one though
[Music]
because number one is world enough in
time
and the doctor falls now if i were to
break down
this two-parter and heaven sent i
probably have more tiny notes to give
on this two-parter by most
i say objective not really but at least
semi-objective measures heavensen is a
better story but it doesn't take my
number one
because this wrap up in this story
especially at the end of the doctor
falls before
setting up twice upon a time but prior
to that
it pulls together everything
that i love about the 12th doctor
if you haven't watched it already this
past saturday i did a video explaining
why the doctor's character arc over his
three series
resonates so tightly
and directly and deeply with me
and this story
is what pulls all of that together if
this hadn't
nailed the giving the exact
definition of feeling and motivation
behind this doctor
his appreciation of who he has become
his reluctance to let that
go i don't want to change again
never again if this didn't have all that
on display
i don't know if that arc that i love so
much would
be as strong what makes that
arc work is how it all pulls together in
this ending here
and without this i don't know if capaldi
would still be my favorite doctor
but with this without the story itself
being perfect because it's not
but whatever little things i have i have
that i might nitpick about it or that i
brought up in the take two reviews it
pulls everything about him that i love
together in a perfect summation of
why i love this doctor i do what i do
because it's right
because it's decent
and above all it's kind and i
cannot do anything other than give that
the top spot because this is the story
that solidifies him
as my doctor my
favorite incarnation of this
character and that's even without
getting into all the amazing tense scary
triumphant sad stuff that goes on over
the story
from what happens to bill and the slow
realization of exactly how horrifying
the conversion into a siren especially
these early clunky versions of cyberman
actually is to the fact that the doctor
realizes he
cannot actually fix this even though he
said that he couldn't he believed it
when he said it
missy and the master and missy making a
decision and an
older version of herself that refuses to
accept that she changed and evolved
rather kill her than let it happen
while the doctor has fully embraced to a
who he has become and is willing to die
for it
it all just
works that's why it's my pick
for the 12th doctor's best story
what is your top 10 for capaldi's era
whatever it is
drop something down the comments and
let's talk about it
i have a patreon you'll see a link up
there
that is how i make my living and how i'm
able to do all this
but even if you're not able to
contribute there there are rewards for
every tier but even if you can't there's
youtube memberships as an option but
even if you can't do that
like share subscribe all of those help
me out
but i don't want to put too much
pressure on you even for that
because at the end of the day you are
the council
i just run the meetings until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]